-First of all,
a big congratulations
to our pal Rufus Wainwright
on his Grammy nomination
for Best Folk Album
for "Folkocracy." Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Covering "Justice
Delivers Its Death,"
please welcome Rufus
and Martha Wainwright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Silver and gold ♪
♪ Silver and gold ♪
♪ Everyone wishes for it ♪
♪♪
♪ How do you measure
its worth? ♪
♪ Just by the pleasure it gives
here on Earth ♪
♪♪
-♪ Oh, I'm getting old ♪
♪ Oh, I'm getting old ♪
♪ Everyone wishes for youth ♪
♪♪
♪ How have I wasted my life? ♪
♪ Trusting the pleasure it gives
here on Earth ♪
♪♪
-♪ Lord, come with fire ♪
♪ Lord, come with fire ♪
♪ Everyone's wasting
their time ♪
♪♪
♪ Storing up treasure in vain ♪
♪ Trusting the pleasure it gives
here on Earth ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, I see the end ♪
♪ Everyone's waiting for death ♪
♪♪
♪ How do you measure
its worth? ♪
♪ Justice delivers its gift here
on Earth ♪
♪♪
-♪ Silver and gold ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Come on now, come on!
The greatest.
Oh, my God! Thank you, buddy.
Thank you.
Congrats on the Grammy, bud.
Rufus and Martha Wainwright!